pas assez de logements sociaux aux
clayes-sous-bois alors c'est la
préfecture des yvelines qui reprend la
main la loi est claire d'ici 2025 les
villes soumises aux dispositifs sru
devront avoir 25 % de logements sociaux
et si elle ne respecte pas le rythme de
construction les sanctions tombent
pénalités financières et droit de
préemption urbain pour l'état autrement
dit la préfecture récupère le contrôle
pour la réalisation de logements sociaux
une injustice pour la mère des
clayes-sous-bois et ne lui manque que 11
logements pour respecter le seuil des
25%
on a beaucoup un sentiment de colère et
d'injustice face à la demie surtout face
à l'administration et à son regard sur
la réalité de ce que l'on vit ce que
vivent les maires dans les communes on
est traité un peu comme des gens qui ont
comment dire qu'ils mettent à font
preuve de mauvaise volonté mais c'est
pas du tout enfin c'est pas le cas dans
le département des yvelines 19 communes
sont particulièrement mis en cause pour
leurs manquements à la loi 79 ans tout
sur la région ile de france la loi sru
vise principalement à rééquilibrer sur
le territoire le parc hlm
un dispositif que la mère de
voisins-le-bretonneux 16 % de logements
sociaux soit très voir appliquée à
l'échelle de l'agglomération
quand la ville nouvelle a été créée par
son voisin était vu comme le quartier
résidentiel qui devait accueillir des
pavillons donc en fait on hérite d'une
histoire qu'on nous reproche aujourd'hui
et ce n'était pas un choix de l'époque
celle de l'état lui même qui a fait le
choix de répartir différents quartiers
comme ça sur saint quentin en yvelines
un projet de loi logement sera dévoilé
au mois de mars prochain le gouvernement
pourrait alors décider d'assouplir dans
certains cas la loi sru